efe es una función lineal algunos de sus
valores se muestran en la tabla a
continuación en esta tablita de aquí
cuáles gráficas representan funciones
que crecen a la misma razón que f así
que primero encontramos la razón de
cambio de f si pasa de que x valga 0 a x
valga 4 entonces tengo un cambio neto de
4 unidades y eso se refleja en un cambio
de d menos 1 pasa 6 así que en un cambio
de 77 unidades positivas en el valor de
f por lo tanto la razón de cambio de f
es de 7 cuartos y quiero encontrar cuál
de estas rectas tiene una pendiente
también de 7 cuartos con lo que es lo
mismo cuál de estas rectas es paralela a
la recta que representa f y bueno el
modo más fácil de hacer eso es graficar
a ese voy a tomar cualesquiera pareja de
puntos
sean parte de los valores que toman efe
podría tomar cualesquiera dos porque es
una función lineal cuando x vale 0 efe
vale menos 1 y cuando x vale 4 cuando x
vale 4 f x vale 6 efe de 4 es 6 así que
estaría aquí de modo que la gráfica de f
se ve algo así es una recta que se ve
así entonces cuál de estas rectas es
paralela a esta recta pues de hecho
puedo decir incluso más puedo decir que
es una recta que crece más rápido que f
es más rápido que f tiene más
inclinación be es una función
decreciente así que ni la tengo que
considerar se crece más lento que ese
está de quilla sf porque la recta tiene
menos inclinación y parece que d es la
opción correcta parece que estas dos
rectas son paralelas vamos a verificarlo
la razón de cambio la razón de cambio de
f es cuánto cambia el valor de la
función dado un cambio en el valor de x
así que bien si cambio x por 4 unidades
si x cambia en 4 unidades
entonces f cambia en 7 unidades de modo
que la pendiente de f es de 7 cuartos
eso significa que si yo me paro en este
punto de la gráfica de d y yo me muevo
cuatro unidades positivas sea me muevo
la derecha cuatro unidades entonces para
que de crezca a la misma razón que f
para regresar a la gráfica a partir de
este punto tendría que alzar me siete
unidades veamos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 en efecto regreso a la
gráfica por lo tanto de tiene la misma
pendiente que f es la opción correcta